هذه الفئران لا تعيش في مستنقعات قذره ولا
في حفر تحت الارض بل تعيش في اجواء من
الرفاهيه والدلال داخل هذا المعبد الخاص
بها في الهند والاغرب من ذلك انها تعبد
كاالهه هناك
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
في وقت تعاني فيه مدن كبيره كباريس
ونيويورك من افه انتشار الفئران والجرذان
وتبذل جهدا كبيرا للتخلص منها يبدو ان
الامر مختلف تماما في مدينه بيكانير
بولايه راجستان شمال غربي الهند فسكان هذه
المدينه يقدسون الفئران ويعكفون في
عبادتها وتقديم الطعام لاعداد كبيره منها
في معبد كارني ماتا الذي تم بناؤه خصيصا
لهذا القرض
المعبد يضم اكثر من 20000
تم احضارها من المجاري والازقه
والمستنقعات لتحظى بالرعايه والاهتمام
السكان هنا يقدمون قرابين للفئران فاكهه
وطعاما وحليبا وكل ما لذ وطاب ليس هذا
فحسب فالسكان بنو ايضا حواجز حول المعبد
تحول بين الفئران المقدسه والقطط الجائعه
التي تنتشر حوله
[موسيقى]
معظم الفئران سوداء والقليله منها بيضاء
وتعتبر مقدسه وعلى الرغم من عدد الفئران
الهائل لم تتاثر المدينه بكنير بالطاعون
ودائما عندما ينفق بعض من هذه الفئران
تتبعها مباشره ولاده فئران اخرى
يوم واتباع هذه الديانه بان الجرذان
والفئران تجسد حي للالهه كرنماتا التي حمل
المعبد اسمها وهي امراه هندوسيه عاشت في
القرن الرابع عشر للميلاد وعبدها اتباعها
وحظيت بالتبجيل على نطاق واسع في البلاد
القوارض هنا لها قدسيه كبيره لدى السكان
فكهنه المعبد يوظبون على تحذير الزوار عند
السير داخله واي شخص يقتل فارا بالخطا
يعاقب وفقا لقوانين المعبد
لكن المفارقه العجيبه انه على بعد كيلو
مترات من هذه المدينه غرب الهند وبالضبط
في مدينه اسام
هذه الفئران والجرذان التي تعبد كالهه في
بيكانير تعتبر وجبه شهيه لدى بعض سكان
مدينه ازام
القرويون هنا يشترون المئات من الفئران
التي تم اصطيادها ثم يعرضونها للبيع بغرض
الاكل في اسواق شعبيه
[موسيقى]
القوارض والجرذان ارتبط اسمها على مدار
التاريخ بكثير من الامراض والاوبئه التي
نقلتها الى البشر وباء الطاعون كان واحدا
منها وقد تسبب بوفاه اكثر من 430 مليون
شخص خلال القرن الرابع عشر ومن الفيروسات
التي تنقلها القوارض للبشر ايضا فايروس
سوهانتا الذي يصيب الرئتين وهو من
الفيروسات القاتله التي لا يوجد لها علاج
او لقاح الى يومنا هذا ويموت نتيجه
الاصابه به حوالي 36 بالمئه من المصابين
عباده الجرذان وتناولها قصتان غريبتان
اخريان من الهند بلد العجائب الذي يزخر
بالاف العادات والامور الغريبه وغير
المالوفه لشعوب العالم الاخر